Hey, this is a really funny caller.
This is a guy who doesn't like me,
but he's very polite and almost endearing in a
certain way. He calls me a fool. He tells me to
shut up, but he actually is sort of polite in
doing it. Take a listen to this. Ah, voicemail.
No, of course, is two one nine two David P..
And David, I'm in Texas, I'm watching your
performance, so I guess the best way to describe
it, it's a rather offensive that you keep
interjecting your opinion, which is so biased.
Well, this is an opinion show. That's what
people. That's what I mean. I
guess that's why people watch.
Do you not watch what happened
with your boy Biden and his son
so corrupt, you fool, shut up. Thank you.
Shut up, you fool. Thank you. I don't know
something about that. I'm I'm finding endearing.
Make sure you sign up at join Pakman dot com to
get access to the bonus show. We will talk about
this. Trump vetoing the military budget threat.
We will talk about a major decision from the
Department of Transportation about service
animals on planes and much, much more. Sign
up at Join Pakman Dotcom. I'll see you then.